dwayne johnson wish he would work out a
little bit more yesterday he tried to
dial it back doing a little fishing
therapy
after his battle with coven 19. and now
only we have the rock
opening up about the emotional roller
coaster that he's been on
over the past couple of years i was just
so
in the moment and grateful i now
pronounce
that you two you are husband and wife
from his wedding to his wife lauren last
august to losing his dad rocky this year
family man dwayne's ups and downs are
chronicled in the new book
through the lens from his photographer
producing partner and friend
hiram garcia something i knew that you
were taking
and some i didn't know this isn't
goodbye this is just uh
i'll see down the road i remember saying
i have no idea what to say for my dad's
eulogy
just started jotting a few things down i
delivered a eulogy
probably two hours later it would make
his heart full the book also captures
the rocks bond with a big little fan
gabriel singleton aka tater a
seven-year-old who lost his battle
with stage four cancer rock you're my
hero these are
strong brave and kind just like me
we're also inspired by you especially me
hold on second oh my gosh tater got to
visit his idol on the baywatch set
getting his own movie poster
dwayne and his family recently recovered
from covet 19 and in this interview
which you can see more of tonight on the
rock's youtube page duane reveals
how this unexpected walk of fame moment
with his daughter jasmine
left many holding their breath i'm gonna
show you what it all means hold on
i walk towards lauren and i start to bed
down
and including my mom and lauren thought
that i was going to propose
and i went up come here let me see jazzy
everyone's like uh we thought you were
going to propose
in that moment no make fun of everybody